hello campers I am Anthony also known as
Deb our tour on free kool Kat and github
and thank you for joining me on the
short height about web design versus web
development the web design is the hell
web development is the one today we're
going to discuss how they work together
to build a beautiful experience for you
and everyone else that visits the
Internet the web designer what they do
will impact the how the user interface
and user experience looks and feel the
web developer what they do will impact
what the user experience and user
interface will do once you start to
clicking on buttons an example is the
login process a designer will decide
where the login process will start on
the page a developer will decide what
that process will entail are you logging
in with your email address your username
or your social media account an example
for building a car a designer will
choose what color the car is is it red
white or blue cloth or leather seats
tinted or not tinted windows a developer
will decide if it's a v6 or a v8 engine
is it a gasoline hybrid or all-electric
vehicle and together they work to build
a beautiful experience for you and
everyone else who visits the internet
again the web designer is the how the
web developer is the what please stay
tuned for the short quiz afterwards